the boys will be packing twice the girl
power this season for the first time
ever the show will feature two female
coaches Miley Cyrus and Alicia Keys I
don't know that we've ever had a shake
up luck this season 11 Miley's the
youthful spirit that we've been missing
he won three times and we're on the 11th
season choosing this great performer but
she also has this ear for music now
mouth Blake and Adam better watch their
backs Miley's not only showing off some
outrageous fashion she wants to mix
things up from her big red chair if
you're rock you get through without her
if you're country though Blake and I
think with me I don't think there's that
genre wall I think if you do country you
could want to be on my team like this
season's other fresh-faced literally is
Alicia Keys
the singer is sticking to the no-makeup
mantra she made back in May and is
carrying the no-frills approach to her
coaching where'd you learn a thing like
that from you oh I feel like I have a
lot to share and like my perspective is
something people will receive I
straight-up love you I just don't know
how honest it is I'm starting to kind of
hear it
Alicia's is the strongest team mine is
probably a not so distant second Blake
is always the weakest team so much his
team just him he broke the news the team
Adam will get support from mentor Sammy
Hagar this is like the most organic
pairing because I'm like hey man I
wanted to ask you about the dynamic this
season how are the girls
handling your and Blake's bickering
they're a little disturbed sometimes a
little shocked but and especially the
stuff you don't see if you notice the
voice I'm hearing Blake's here and that
will never change
we're like the weird bookends as much as
the world likes to make this girl
catfight scenario that's actually Blake
and Adam what's the opposite of play
chill
what Lukey
I'm trying to speak honestly to Ally
just hanging out over here your drivers
here he's ready to take you whenever
you're done